hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and ah
[Music]
i'm just checking in on you i'm just
checking in on you and i'm not even
gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat it
i am losing my [ __ ] mind today
losing my [ __ ] mind today jesus
christ
just every [ __ ] day i can't i can't i
can't take a [ __ ] day off
i thought i had this i i you know my
daughter
right it was her birthday yesterday
right her fourth birthday so i made her
this uh vanilla confetti cake i [ __ ]
the thing up
i left the cakes in too long you know
because she had come home with the cold
you know i caught it from her and then
we're like oh [ __ ] do we have covid
so we get tested for covid rapid test
you know comes back negative which i
swear to god i must have blown [ __ ]
two grand on those things
um comes back negative well at least
it's not that so now i'm feeling
myself i'm getting sick but i gotta make
this [ __ ] cake
so it was like stick the cake in the
oven 30 to 35 minutes so i just set the
timer
on 32 and a half and i just took it out
and i didn't even
i should have checked so it was not one
of the most disgusting words out there
unless you're talking about a cake
moist i hate that [ __ ] word
it was not it was it was it was i either
mixed it too much
or i left it in too long or a
combination of both and i bit into it i
knew it sucked and then everybody at the
birthday party told me it was good and i
knew it wasn't good
i knew it wasn't good but i was like i'm
not going to [ __ ] sit here and have a
uh
oh boohoo you guys are just saying that
and ruined my daughter's birthday so i
was just like i know they know it sucks
i'll just i just made a mental note of
what i have to do next time
so anyway
i know what i'm talking so today you
know i was gonna go fly and i was just
like you know what
i'm not feeling good so i'm not gonna
fly so i you know i just don't fly i'm
like oh wow look at this you know
that's usually a two hour two and a half
hour chunk out of my day
leave that [ __ ] thing wide open and
then i swear to god the second it opens
up all the
i get all these text messages oh by the
way yeah yeah we got this [ __ ] zoom
call but
all this [ __ ] and it's just like what
the [ __ ] were you gonna [ __ ] tell me
that
i swear to god you ever feel like you're
in the [ __ ] truman show
and it's just like an experiment how
much can it take right
let's pull this out okay we're graphing
the emotions he seems happy
he seems happy he's gonna lay on the
couch and just [ __ ] enjoy himself
sending the text in three two one
oh [ __ ] yourself freckles
right and then meanwhile something great
is happening
today but also you know a little
inconvenient is i have this shitty
insulation
um inside my old house that is now a
nice house but i'll never make my money
back unless i live to be 90.
um because i put so much money into this
[ __ ] house um
i had like that that uh the porno
spray you know you know you can actually
roll it out and have the nice insulation
or someone can just do the money shot
with the insulation i had that [ __ ] so
of course we also have plumbing
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucking [ __ ] problems
and they rooted the [ __ ] pipes up
into the attic and then came down into
the bathroom
so the plumber stuck his head up there
he's like jesus christ i'm not sifting
through this [ __ ] new year's eve time
square horse [ __ ]
you gotta vacuum it out of here right so
i'm like all right so now i got these
guys
they're vacuuming it out so the game
plan
is they're gonna vacuum it out and then
the plumber's gonna come by he's gonna
stick his head up there he's gonna see
what the situation is
and then and then know what he has to do
then they're gonna roll the new [ __ ] in
and he'll know where all the plumbing is
and all of that stuff then he can just
sort of roll it back
you know like when they just roll in the
grass on somebody's front yard there
right
so um i end up i'm talking to my
my lovely wife about it all right and
it's just like
okay so what's the deal i go they're
gonna vacuum this stuff out
he's going to look at it and then put
the new stuff in she goes
no they're going to take it out and then
put it back in
and then he's going to come up and look
and i'm like
what i go they're going to take it out
and put it back in and she goes yeah
i go they're gonna take out the stuff we
don't want and then put it back in
aren't they gonna put the new stuff in
and she goes yeah i go what you just
said they're gonna take it out and put
it back in
i go they're taking out the old stuff
and then putting
the new stuff in right she goes yeah
that's what i meant and i'm like well
that's not what you said you said
they're gonna take it out and put it
back
in and then i'm like is the guy gonna
look in between
she's like no he's gonna come saturday
so i'm like well wait wait wait a minute
wait they're gonna take it out
danny's gonna stick his head up and look
and then they put the new [ __ ] in
she goes no they're gonna take it out
put it back in and then he's gonna come
on set
or they're gonna leave it out and i'm
just like
can we get on the same pronoun page
please
i i literally stood in my foyer for
[ __ ] i should have had a little
[ __ ] uh what it was a little hat that
[ __ ] uh
costello used to wear i was just waiting
for my wife to
take it out then put it back in and
first base
oh my god it just it just i just
[ __ ] meanwhile i know you're probably
thinking bill this isn't that big a deal
just imagine having this conversation
while there's a shop vac going
in the background the entire time so
it's more like
they're gonna take it out and then put
put the new stuff in they're gonna take
it out no they're gonna take it out put
it back
in that doesn't make any sense
i swear to god i swear i was standing on
the stairways and at one point
i just wanted to just jump head first do
a sailor's dive right down to the last
step and just [ __ ] end it
so now she's gonna send me the plumber's
name cause now she's saying
that they they're taking it out and
they're just gonna leave it out and the
[ __ ] new [ __ ] is gonna sit on my
front
[ __ ] walkway
and then the guy's gonna come by
saturday i'm like well it's gonna
[ __ ] rain
it's i swear i swear to [ __ ] god i
swear to god
they're gonna take it out and put it
back in why would they take it out and
put it back in what the [ __ ] are we
doing
first base
[Music]
and then in the end of all of that i'm
the [ __ ] because i think now my wife
is [ __ ] pissed at me and it's just
like
i i i can't even get into it and then i
can't even say i can't even state the
obvious of the whole [ __ ] situation
because that's going too far because
this is a [ __ ] hilarious argument we
got into right
um oh we got a couple [ __ ] arguments
yeah we got a couple [ __ ] arguments
like last night after the birthday right
like she does she never cuts up boxes
right she just throws them in the
laundry room and then i come by and i
become like box boy
and it [ __ ] drives me up the wall so
last night i'm feeling [ __ ] sick i'm
trying to fight this [ __ ] thing off
and i go into the laundry room to drop
off something and i see like you know a
bunch of boxes from the birthday just
sitting there
then i'm like wait a minute oh my god i
got to take out the trash
tomorrow's trash what the [ __ ] right
so and i see all these just the way they
were thrown in there i took it
personally
like yeah you [ __ ] cut him up right
so i'm [ __ ] right
around i'm [ __ ] mutter i'm a
muttering
pasty freckled [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] and
i'm [ __ ] spiderman in the [ __ ]
trash can making all this [ __ ] noise
like a goddamn bear
going through these things so of course
she comes downstairs and she's like what
was that all about
i was gonna cut him up that's that's
what she always says i was gonna cut
just gas let you i was gonna do it
so i just sat there and i said okay i i
i just started going i know i know
i know i was gonna cut him up i said
that and i took the baby out there
and i was gonna cut him up i just kept
going i know i know i know
i know and she goes what are you just
being an [ __ ] now i go no okay okay
i'll give you that
let's just say you were gonna come down
and you were gonna cut him up all right
me flipping out
is about the 900 previous times
when you didn't so then she went totally
bill clinton on me
she went full-on [ __ ] politician
she just starts talking about it you
know this morning we [ __ ]
know this morning you know this is a
great country remember i used to do that
like bill bill clinton uh did you just
bomb that country
to get uh the story of you getting a
blow job off the front pages
and he'd be like you know when i grew up
in arkansas
the air was fresh the water was cleaned
let's is the america i want to get back
to it's just like that
i always [ __ ] hate the next reporter
because then he goes to the next
reporter i want the next report to be
like hey
you know you didn't answer that person's
question
what the [ __ ] reporters are so about
oh what if he answers mike my question
and i get it in the gazette i get the
scoop oh boy oh boy i'm [ __ ] jimmy
olsen
then he does it to him he just keeps
[ __ ] doing it it's the craziest thing
ever
i don't mean to single out clinton but
they all [ __ ] do it but he he he he
was the master
so anyways i go it was about those other
900 times so she tried to spin it in
two hour in the morning evidently i was
a douche when i wasn't a douche i should
have had her on for this podcast
um you know what i'm going to have her
on the next one to the
because this isn't fair that you just
hear in my side of the story
she like my daughter came in and i
thought she said dad can i have some
waffles
but she said can you i guess she wanted
me to make him you know and once again
you know she's
four years old so she doesn't you know
once again doesn't
say it the right way sometimes so i just
said oh yeah hey that's great
so my wife comes in the room mind you
i'm getting sick and i'm sitting there
i literally drank nyquil because we
didn't mean dayquil at like [ __ ]
eight in the morning
which i'll tell you dude that is a
[ __ ]
that puts you on the time zone on the
other side of the planet right
so then my lovely wife comes in and
she's just like you're still laying in
bed and she had like this [ __ ] panic
she goes i thought you were gonna make
her make her waffles
i didn't say that then she got all like
flipped out and i was just like honey
relax like it takes me two seconds
i'll go downstairs so then she tried
with the box thing to drag that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
of a miscommunication while i'm sitting
there on nyquil
tell ya i've had a hell of a [ __ ] 36
hours here
so anyway she sits there oh last night
in the argument she goes
and then i went out and i got you a bone
broth soup and i was like no you didn't
you postmated it
and i paid for that and then she got mad
at me going you don't say that
don't throw that in my [ __ ] face but
you get to act like you went out you
didn't go out you just moved your
[ __ ] thumbs
unbelievable un [ __ ] believable
but i'll tell you this so i love her to
death
i love her to death and i know how to
fix all of this
i can fix all of this with that little
cutie cake i'm just going to take her
out to lunch
that's all you got i finally learned
that that women are just as simple as
guys
it's just you have to go do some woman
[ __ ]
you know that that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna [ __ ] take her out we're
gonna go
we're gonna go to some [ __ ] place
that one of her friends recommended
well we can't it's a [ __ ] lock down
here whatever i'll i'll figure something
out we'll go we'll eat it in the car
we'll get two straws and stick it in a
drink
and you know what and then i'll
apologize for everything that i was
right about and then
i think you know it's easy that's all
you have to do that's all you have to do
to just [ __ ] keep the ball moving
keep it moving um i did mike tyson's
podcast
everybody the great iron mike tyson
the most electrifying heavyweight
champion that i ever saw
um no disrespect to muhammad ali i was a
little too
young for his time when i finally saw
him he fought uh leon spinks
was the first time i saw him so he was
at towards the end
um but as far as like
seeing a fighter come on the scene and
just
absolutely dominate and just be must-see
tv every time he fought uh mike tyson
was the guy
and i got to do his uh podcast it was
mike tyson
and his co-host uh jeremy piven and we
had a great time that podcast
is up right now and um
i have to tell you there's only a couple
times in my life
that i have met the greatest to ever do
whatever it is that they do
uh and that was one of those moments and
i could not believe that i
i couldn't believe when i walked in and
i shook his hand i couldn't believe
i couldn't believe it you know i just
couldn't believe i i was there was an
element of that
surrealness throughout the whole podcast
and he was
an absolute sweetheart of a guy
and i had so much fun joking around and
all that
and uh it's it's up uh i guess we get
all podcasts i should check that out i
had a great time
all right and with that um
once again my theory by the way that
they need to shut down fox news
and cnn and msnbc and all of these
24-hour
not news channels they need to get rid
of all of these things
okay like if you watch the [ __ ] local
news
versus watching those to see how
differently that the news is presented
and i love the local news because they
give you some sort of feel-good story
at the end of it right they have to
because they live in your city
they can't just be bumming you out the
whole time and then they're gonna run
into you at trader joe's and it's just
like you [ __ ] depressing [ __ ]
how about a [ __ ] story about some old
lady you know who's still doing setups
in her 90s
can you throw me a [ __ ] olive branch
right those national news guys they
don't give a [ __ ]
doing the news under a mountain in some
[ __ ] state you don't even know where
it's at right
so anyway i go on facebook because i'm
old right i love facebook facebook you
know
i keep going back for facebook what i
like about facebook is we drove the all
of us old people drove the youth
out of it you know and then they all
leave thinking we miss them
okay we have politics to talk about
dude and i gotta tell you go on facebook
and if you have a nice wide variety of
friends we have people on the right and
the left
if you look at how the way that they
were talking about trump
leaving i had this dude that i went to
high school with
he did everything but get on his knees
and blow trump
thank you for this thank you for that
thank you for making the economy this
thank you for you
thank you for being a trooper david
being the first real president i mean
just [ __ ]
i mean i have seen rock and roll hall of
fame inductee speeches
that were less ball washing than what
the [ __ ] this guy wrote
and then i got one of my larry liberals
on the other side
was talking about trump leaving he said
does anybody else feel that the same
feeling after you take a giant dump
that this guy's out of here the fact
that both of those people feel that
their perception of that man is a
hundred percent right
is um what is wrong with fox news
and cnn and msnbc um
and that is how big the divide is
and uh like i just don't understand um
i don't understand why smart people
are just getting drawn into that
i know i keep popping on this but does
anybody else like not watch those news
channels and then when you talk to
somebody who watches either one
or all three they all sound [ __ ]
crazy
did you hear what mitch mcconnell said
now i know you have to pay attention to
know what's going on i guess i mean
how are we going to stop it but like i i
just don't think it's
you're listening to uh
you just listen you're listening to
basically like propaganda
you know what i mean it's kind of like
you know if you
if you look at how we talk about our
foreign policy and then how other people
talk about a foreign policy just how
completely
opposite it is where it's just like
you know we're defending freedom where
we're well
the people on the other side of that
[ __ ] are all just going like
you know you guys are [ __ ] war
criminals you pieces of [ __ ] you're the
[ __ ] devil
your country is hades you know like do
you remember when uh
osama bin laden would call us infidels
i remember just thinking like uh i i i
had to look up the word it's like
jesus christ this guy's perception of me
and all of my friends like we're just a
bunch of jerk-offs
and as far as me traveling around i kind
of learned that you know
most people it's so [ __ ] up most
people are just walking around they're
trying to get a sandwich
you know they want to feel safe they
want to find love they want a job that
they're excited to go to
that's about as deep as it goes like
they're not walking around
plotting against other nations that's
the sociopath
[ __ ] lunatic [ __ ] that are running
for office and the money behind
them and if elected
and if elected i would say that we go
beyond is beyond the pale is that what
is it you got to go past fox news you
got to go past cnn and msnbc
you got to go past the democratic
candidate
you got to go past the republican
candidate the libertarian candidate
sitting there with his mittens in his
earmuffs
you go past all of that
walk behind that curtain and you get to
the blue blood money
that told us the gas combustion engine
not only was a better choice was more
powerful
than electricity if you see what these
teslas
are doing to all of these loud ass
[ __ ] gas combustion cars the whole
thing was a [ __ ] lie
it's a hundred year [ __ ] lie
they actually had people believing that
electricity wasn't powerful
there's no horsepower dude i got to tell
you something
man those [ __ ] teslas
okay let's let's call a spade a spade
not a good looking car
all right the suv one's actually pretty
cool
all right i think it's because i'm just
so used to seeing a grill
so the air can get into the radiator to
help cool the antifreeze right
it's just new you know
here's those things are [ __ ]
like i thought i had a fast car
you know what i mean you got a fast car
right halfway decent i think it was like
super fast but you know supercharged v6
not that heavy a car right
i put it in uh i put it in when i i
click on the
checkered flag suspension mode and all
of a sudden my blue lights become red
like my car just got angry and oh it's
ready to tear up the road
dude i can't even tell you how many
times i have it in that mode and there's
a
there's a woman in one of those tesla
suvs full of [ __ ] kids
and the light turns green and she's just
gone gone
one more time for effect gone yeah the
whole thing was a [ __ ] lie
all right this is just my theory of
someone who doesn't read doesn't watch
the [ __ ] news
okay doesn't know who his senators are
you know and and and cannot even have a
conversation
about insulation coming in and out of
his house without getting confused okay
so take all of this
with a giant grain of salt all right but
my solution
for the world's problems i delivered
this with more confidence if i was
smoking a cigar then i really think i
knew [ __ ]
i we just everybody
gm ford chrysler
porsche all these guys you just switch
over
to electric cars you do it in aviation
all of that [ __ ]
everything becomes [ __ ] electric
all right i think the air would get
cleaner i think we have enough oil in
this country
to [ __ ] you know
keep anything else that needs oil going
getting outside oh i'm really outside my
above my pig right here right then we
don't have to be over in the middle east
and when we leave the middle east they
will just pick up with where the [ __ ]
they were
before we got there and considering
they've been fighting for thousands and
thousands
now there's the thing i don't want
people in the middle east to be fighting
and i went over there to uh
israel did a show in tel aviv stayed in
jaffa and it was [ __ ] beautiful
and i gotta tell you something the
israeli and the palestinian william
women that will walk around
drop dead gorgeous me and bartnik
sitting there like the [ __ ] are these
people fighting about
sitting right on the mediterranean sea
was one of the most beautiful relaxed
peaceful places
i'd ever been but down there in
jerusalem oh jesus
[ __ ] was flying so you do away with the
gas combustion engine
all right you switch over to this [ __ ]
you make all religions illegal okay
and rather than having one world bank
you just have one world religion which
is you can believe whatever the [ __ ] you
want to believe
okay but you are not allowed to get
annoyed by somebody else because they
believe something else
does that work i mean no no that doesn't
work
that wouldn't work you gotta have the
ten commandments
you gotta have that [ __ ] but we have
laws right
i don't [ __ ] know it just doesn't
make any sense to me but i gotta tell
you something being on facebook like the
old person that i am and watching two
[ __ ] people
i mean this one guy i swear to god you
would have thought he was talking about
a war hero
the way he was talking about trump and
then the other guy
you know you would you would have
thought like he was talking about you
know
some guy that married his sister became
an alcoholic and started beating her and
she finally got out of the relationship
i mean that is how far apart
and what kills me is those guys could be
neighbors
sitting in their house all they're doing
is watching two different
channels
i mean that is [ __ ] insane that is
[ __ ]
insane or am i insane
i don't know little rumbling bumbling
stumbling donny trump
i don't know i i i will say that i don't
understand how somebody could like
be uh a trump supporter and not think
that he didn't go out like isaiah thomas
and not even say biden's name and not
even concede
none of that [ __ ] i mean i mean come on
i mean how hardcore a trump fan are you
if you can't look at that and just see
say that he was kind of acting like he
had on a giant diaper in a rattle all
right
and i'm not saying you know
that joe biden in uh what's her face
there kamala
are the solution i'm not saying that
either because i i think that they're
gonna get us into
another war um
i have no [ __ ] idea i don't know
what's gonna [ __ ] happen okay but i'm
done i'm just glad
i'm glad that like
i i don't know what i'm just happy that
i you know when trump got elected
unfortunately i was booked on a talk
show it's
a conan show and i was just like it's
gonna be fine what's a big [ __ ] deal
[Laughter]
i had no idea the [ __ ] show that was
gonna happen that was [ __ ]
that was wild that was a [ __ ] wild
ride i will
i will tell you that um whatever that
was that was a [ __ ] wild ride and i'm
you know the same way i was rooting for
donnie
which i still think his undoing was
coveted if the dumb bastard had just
said hey let's all get together and work
on this rather than saying hey wearing a
[ __ ] mask and no one around me wears
a mask
that is classic control freak behavior
and i actually
know somebody who did that
that actually has like a medical
background did that
and this person was a total control
freak worked for themselves
and what happened was kovid [ __ ]
with this dude's sense of control so he
had to rebel
and you know what the dumbass went out
and he [ __ ] got it like an idiot
um all right let's read some [ __ ]
um advertising here um and i'm not
saying if
you get kovid you're an idiot i'm just
saying that if you deliberately go out
and not do what the [ __ ] they say not to
do then yeah that's
stupid behavior all right stitch fix
everybody
s-t-i-t-c-h fix online shopping
can be daunting oh what website do i go
to
uh you never know if things will fit
that's true
returns are difficult i'm not going to
argue there and you don't even know what
store to start with i mean
hey you're preaching to the fire here's
[ __ ]
uh this season let stitch fix do all the
hard work
as the days get longer how old is this
copy this season what season are we in
it's not christmas season is it
valentine's season
the days are not getting longer wait
they are getting longer as the days get
long you're right i was thinking of
the nights get longer all right once
again i'm wrong
you know i'm gonna call my wife up and
apologize i'm sure i was wrong about all
that [ __ ] i ranted about but i'll tell
you what oh i'll tell you what it felt
good
it felt good be an old billy wright
brother for a second
um as the days get longer
and the weather gets colder it may be
time to take a look at your winter
wardrobe
if you want to make a change this season
season stitch fix can help you
choose a new new pieces you're gonna
love
uh if your go-to outfit in 2020 has
become sweatshirts or yoga pants guilty
as charged
uh you may be feeling like you're in a
style rut
let stitch fix help you feel excited
about what you're wearing
did you just look over your current cold
weather wardrobe options and get a chill
it's time to ditch that old sweater and
upgrade that jacket
a stitch fix personal stylist can help
you pick new pieces
that are timeless oh wouldn't that be
great
everything seems to be so disposable how
often do you hear timeless in
advertising
stitch fix offers clothing hand selected
by expert stylist for your
unique size style and budget every piece
is chosen
for your fit and your life and it's the
easy solutions
it's the easy solution to finding what
makes you look and feel your best
try on pieces that yeah don't meditate
and work on yourself get a new outfit
try on pieces at home before you keep
before you buy
keep your favorites and send back the
rest stitch fix has free shipping
easy returns in exchange and a prepay
return envelope is included
there's no subscription required what's
what you you meditate you work on
yourself but now you want to go out
there and you want to catch you know you
want to
you want to call in fall in love right
catch some broad looking at you
you got to look your best right you want
to look like you're
you have your own helicopter and you're
on your way to aspen you want that snow
suit
um there's no subscription required try
stitch fix
once or set up automatic deliveries
you'll pay just a 20
styling fee for each box which gets
credited toward pieces you keep
and there's no hidden fees ever stitch
fix has styles of clothing to fit any
occasion for women men and kids they
ship all over the u.s and are available
in the uk
as well get started today at
stitchfix.com
mmp and you'll get 25 off when you keep
uh everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com
mmp for 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix stitchfix.com mmp
you know they probably throw one pea
soup sweater in there because they can't
get rid of it no no no you gotta keep
everything in the box
[ __ ] um all right headspace everyone
headspace man
hey man like even in the new year man
it's hard to start a new routine man but
hey man
if you're one of the 34 percent of
americans man i mean why are there
countries why are there borders man i
mean isn't that just imaginary lines
made up by the man man
um of americans who made a resolution to
be less
stressed headspace is here to help
headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness i can have my soothing voice
for this
in the form of guided meditation in an
easy to use app
headspace meditation starts at just one
minute a day
they even have a set of walking
meditations so easy
so they're easy to fit excuse me i made
a mistake but
aren't mistakes part of life just
breathe just
just let that mistake go by in your
reading bill just
like a shirt you're putting it on a coat
hanger like it's at a dry cleaner it's
just disappearing
and just know you're going to go back
into this copy and you're just going to
read it you're just going to feel great
about it
even if you make another mistake you're
not going to take it out on the people
that you love and live with
it's just installation
what if they take out and put it back in
the same thing wouldn't that just be
recycling
isn't that what you're about okay back
to the they even have set a set of
walking meditations so easy
[ __ ] they even have set
they even have set of walk oh there's a
[ __ ] letterman they even have a set
of walking meditations so they're easy
to fit into the big
the busiest of schedules headspace is
proven to help you feel
[ __ ] better dude i'm doing [ __ ]
headspace
consider yourself lucky you [ __ ]
clock sucker
their approach to mindfulness can reduce
stress
improve sleep boost focus and increase
your overall sense of well-being
and you don't have to be a guru
headspace is great for all levels of
meditation whether you tried it before
or just a beginner
who's curious or intimidated by it um
hosts to talk about their experience
with headspace hey man like before
headspace man i didn't say man as much
as i say it now man
um i love meditation i should do it more
okay
you can hear it in my okay okay i'll
tell you
i got thunder and lightning between my
ears okay baby all right headspace is
backed by
25 published studios studies sorry on
its
benefits six hundred thousand five star
reviews
and over 60 million downloads
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice
with mindfulness that works for you or
your schedule anytime anywhere
you deserve to feel happier and
headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.comburr that's
headspace.comburr
for a free one-month trial with access
to headspaces full library of
meditations
for every situation man
i asked for the red salsa they gave me
the green salsa man
this is the best deal offered right now
head to headspace dot com yan slash burr
today no it's headspace.com
b-u-r-r today get your mind right
[ __ ]
all right okay i think that is the
podcast i think the bruins are playing
the [ __ ] filthy flyers
tonight i don't know what happened to
celtics i thought they were playing
yesterday
let's just check the old scheds here
celtics schedule
celtics said tomorrow at three at 4 30.
okay they got the 76s
all right and then the bruins i think we
have the flyers tonight right bruins
schedule bruins biggest problem we ain't
scoring any goals our defense
has been fine so far um
not having chara has not hurt us
uh today at 4 pm today at 4 p.m
there we go all right so we got we got
the celtics today 4 p.m my time 7 p.m
east coast 6 p.m central
5 p.m mountain 11 30
hawaiian time you know i was actually
reading up about how we annexed
hawaii um
added them to our country they were kind
of like it's weird they were like stuck
between a rock and a hard place like
finland when they were playing between
hitler and stalin when they were between
us and japan it's like which group of
people that thinks they are god's chosen
one
is going to absorb us you know
why do i talk about [ __ ] like this just
because i glanced at it on wikipedia
all right that is the podcast everybody
um
godspeed keep watching your 24-hour news
networks i'm telling you if you want to
be happy you want some headspace man
watch local news
they give a [ __ ] about your sports teams
and i'm telling you in the end they're
always good i just do a joke about it
till the end
they scare the [ __ ] out of you but in
the end they show some old lady that
makes their own jam
and it makes you feel they bring you
back they they let you down easy
okay as opposed to the anderson coopers
the tucker carlson's
that wolf blitzer guy every day there's
a situation right
[ __ ] guy it's like you know do you
ever just take a [ __ ] day off from
scaring people
what do you think they must be great on
halloween you know considering all the
[ __ ] they say during the day can you
imagine what they maybe they go the
opposite
way but i would think that like how
scary a [ __ ] 24-hour news network
anchor
like you know you're like hey we're
gonna carve some jack-o'-lanterns
that's not [ __ ] scary compared to the
[ __ ] i'm talking about every day
let's go [ __ ] buy a cobra off the
dark web and we'll set it loose and we
got to find it
everybody puts on a beekeeper suit you
got to try to catch the thing that's
probably
what their [ __ ] party's like all
right i've always stayed my welcome all
right
um have a great weekend you [ __ ] and
i'll check in on you
on monday no i'll i'll i'll do my monday
morning podcast i'm checking in on you
right now
now i'm confused all right this is gonna
be a little bit of music
uh by the great andrew themist and then
it's gonna be a half hour bonus episode
of the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast
from a thursday afternoon podcast from a
few years ago all right that is it
check out the mike tyson podcast i'll
see you
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
january 21st 2013.
how's it going did you get the day off
on martin
luther king day is it martin luther king
day i think it is
i'm not sure i have no [ __ ] idea
um i saw it mentioned somebody said
something about martin luther king
on the internet on facebook and it was a
white guy
so i figure white guys will only comment
about martin luther king
around martin luther king day so i'm
going with that
you know this is one of these times of
year where it's [ __ ] uh george
washington day and lincoln day
that's president's day that's the same
day there's a couple of these days here
where all of a sudden everybody's got a
day off and i'm suspecting that people
have a day off
because uh i went over to nhl.com to see
if the bruins were playing tonight and
lo and behold they're playing right now
one to one after one period
you know and i'm like well who the [ __ ]
is at that game
shouldn't everybody be at work and i was
like wait a minute some white guy said
something about martha
oh [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] day off
it's a beautiful day off in the
neighborhood
um how great is it that hockey's back
for hockey fans i can't believe how much
i missed it
um i actually started this podcast late
because i wanted to watch the first
period
um on my computer
i watched a ton of sports this weekend i
will get to the football and my patriots
losing
um which dude what [ __ ] it i'll get to
it right now
did i call it or did i call it huh
i've been telling you all year the
patriots defense stinks
and that [ __ ] what's his face talib
quietly i'm gonna [ __ ] you say his name
that guy
was the glue that was holding that thing
together he was shutting down that whole
side of the field when he pulled up lame
with this hamstring there i was
i texted verzie i said watch joe flacco
air quote heat up and that was the end
of it
and uh that's it i don't know how many
more [ __ ] examples you need i don't
give a [ __ ] how good your quarterback is
if you don't have a [ __ ] defense
you're gonna lose and i shut it off
before i had to watch ray lewis cry
again and thank jesus
you know for helping him to win this
football game when jesus does not give a
[ __ ]
you know i would never say this to ray
lewis i wouldn't even say it to his
[Laughter]
[Music]
nostrils
i don't know why it's the first thing i
thought of when that guy gets going his
[ __ ] nose starts flaring
he's literally like a goddamn bull
probably forget about one of the
greatest
he's basically the the lt of uh i
wouldn't even say he's not no one's lt
lt is lt but whatever he's the closest
thing to lt that the afc has ever had
but uh when that guy gets going man i
just you know
he's the kind of guy you would just
agree to whatever the [ __ ] he was saying
once he [ __ ] gets going
you know i watched the thing on ray
lewis one time i think i brought this up
before
they did a behind the scenes whatever
you know beyond the lines with without
that original espn guy right
and they did a whole thing on [ __ ]
ray lewis and ray lewis was talking
about his dad
that took off on him i don't know if you
guys have ever seen this
and uh he and ray went to the same high
school his dad went to
and he always wanted his dad to show up
to a game and his dad never showed up so
he just started breaking his dad's
records
and he starts getting all intense he's
like in every record that i broke
and they're playing this [ __ ]
keyboard in the background just one note
just
this intense [ __ ] one with this weird
effect on it
it was the most intense thing i ever saw
in my life i the
it was so [ __ ] unreal i actually i
went to the gym for two weeks straight
that's how that's how inspiring ray
lewis is
every day i'd wake up and i you know
after like three days you know
i start slipping back into who i really
am which is a [ __ ] [ __ ] who wants to
lay on the couch
and eat cheese doodles but i just kept
hearing his you know i just kept here
you know ray lewis would go to the gym
ray lewis is at the [ __ ] gym right
now
doing butterflies with his nostrils you
know just flaring them out
so anyways yeah i didn't stick around to
watch that
jesus does not care you know or or god
or or yahweh whoever the [ __ ] you pray
to you've got to think that you know
ahead of his laundry list of dreams that
he's going to make true would probably
be people uh i'm being held captive
uh i think they're gonna saw my head off
on al jazeera
uh i i make nike [ __ ] sneakers in a
sweatshop
how about uh how about a cubicle god can
you hook me up how about about
every other saturday maybe i could only
work 17 hours
i think those prayers are a little
higher on the uh
on the list you know then can i please
win this
this this footy game but um anyways i'm
actually
excited about the uh super bowl and i
was kind of glad the patriots lost in a
way because i didn't want to see tom
brady lose another [ __ ] super bowl
and listen to morons be like oh what was
it for
and now now what's with him
like you can literally like oh he was
the [ __ ] and could win super bowls and
what now he forgot how to do it
you know i i don't i ca i can't talk to
people
i can't talk to people who do [ __ ] and
also like people who will be like the
pages dude they were [ __ ] nine and a
half point favorites eight and a half at
game time what the [ __ ] dude
what a [ __ ] upset right
you know that [ __ ] espn [ __ ]
look this is the deal morons
morons in general gamble on on football
and when playoffs come around playoffs
every mo it's like the super bowl
everybody didn't even [ __ ] watch
shows up to watch that goddamn game and
it's the same thing with playoffs these
gamblers
who don't watch come out of the [ __ ]
weekend warrior gamblers they come out
they don't know [ __ ] about football you
know
they barely watch it but they know tom
brady and bill belichick
oh they playing let me put some money on
them
that's why the spread is so wide
you know what i mean that's what it that
that's basically what it is
it's it's vegas is trying to get money
on both sides of the ball
so what they have to do is because
there's so many [ __ ] rubes out there
who the second they see tom brady and
that dimple in his chin
and his [ __ ] uggs they're going to
throw down 100 bucks on him
basically at that point if the patriots
win they're going to lose their shirts
so they
they got to [ __ ] expand the spread
everybody else who's been watching all
year
is like well wait a minute the [ __ ]
patriots played the ravens earlier this
year and the game was 31 to 30. we lit
up 30 [ __ ] points to this team only
one by one why the [ __ ] would we
be nine and a half point favorites a
mere four months later
you know i don't know
or is this hindsight is 20 20 i'm just
saying whatever congratulations to the
ravens
uh once again your defense has got you
there
and i for one i'm gonna miss ray lewis
but i am not gonna miss
playing the [ __ ] ravens with that
goddamn defense i'm not
and i think you have trent dilfer 2.0 at
quarterback
i'm not buying into this guy i actually
had a conversation with somebody and i
was like i
don't he goes come on man he goes he
doesn't stink he's in the top 10 in the
league i don't think he is
i think he's like 12. you know
i would put peyton brady brees
aaron rodgers
i put matt ryan ahead of him and i had
my voice crack when i said it matt ryan
people i would put matt ryan ahead of
him
i'd rather have aunt what the [ __ ] is
with my voice
um i gotta go see a nutritionist so it
says here in your chart that you're
experiencing
phlegm and your voice is cracking on
your podcast
um i put andrew luck i'd rather have
andrew luck than joe flacco
who else can to throw out there to piss
off some baltimore family and that could
be pissed they're in the super bowl
so here we go harbaugh versus harbaugh
competing for daddy's attention
who do you think is going to win you
know
i'll tell you right now this is the only
way i feel the ravens are gonna win
okay because uh i i this is
is jim harbaugh i think
the only thing he has to worry about is
right now he is
unbelievably undernourished
am i the only guy who's noticed the
transformation
in his [ __ ] chest his neck his
shoulders and his face
he he used to be [ __ ] jacked and i
swear to god i think that that guy is
looking at
x's and o's in some walk-in closet in
the bowels
of [ __ ] candlestick for like 20 hours
a day and he's not eating
because now he's wearing dockers he's
starting to look like bill clinton used
to look before the heart attack where
he's got those mother and hips
and he's getting all [ __ ] gaunt
somebody's got to get that guy a steak
you know get him some some [ __ ] uh
what do you call those things dumbbells
get him something
perfect push-up i don't know what it is
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
how he dresses he's been wearing that
stupid black pullover
that linty thing with those dockers man
he's he's
he's scaring me you know somebody get
that guy a sandwich you'd be like listen
i know you're driven but for the love of
god can you [ __ ] eat something
we're right we're right on the cusp um
but you know i don't have any major
predictions other than i think the 49ers
are going to win
i think they're going to i think that uh
i just don't i think their defense is
good enough
i don't you know i don't [ __ ] i don't
know [ __ ] about the ford 49ers are weird
they play the patriots they put up 31
points on us and our shitty defense and
then they play seattle which i think is
the that team's the future in the nfc if
they can
keep everybody there they they got that
unbelievable defense they [ __ ] shut
them down
they play the falcons the falcons are
[ __ ] scoring points like a goddamn
pinball machine
to start it out so i don't know i don't
know that i have that much faith in
those guys
as much as i did a few months ago but i
do know this i don't think anybody
listening really gives a [ __ ]
good lord am i turning into one of those
analysts i'll tell you if i'm the
[ __ ] 49ers defense i got to be
thinking
um oh here's one did you guys watch uh
did you guys watch the lance armstrong
oprah winfrey
in-depth interview hang on one second
let me do a little advertising before i
get into that because that's gonna be a
[ __ ] long one
uh what do we got here everybody
legal zoom legal zooms back on the
podcast an old friend comes back
coming here to help you once again um
anyways
you know what to you need to accomplish
at the start of this year
huh have you been sitting around oh wait
that's a statement
you know what you need to accomplish at
the start of this new year sorry this is
new copy
you need to think about legal protection
for your family and business
but where do you turn for affordable
legal solutions you can trust
legalzoom.com with an a rating from the
better business bureau that's huge by
the way
if you get the a rating for the better
business bureau you know especially if
you can do something
as important as protecting your family
and you're going to do it online
you know you don't want to go to
scumbag.com all right with an a rating
for
from the better business bureau
legalzoom has been helping families and
businesses get
personalized legal protection for the
past 12 years
huh they've been in business 12 years
and they're still getting an a which
means they've been treating people right
whether you need to incorporate your
business from an llc or protect your
family with the will or a living trust
all legal zoom documents are state
specific and their step-by-step process
makes it simple
and with legalzoom you can even access
an extensive network of legal plan
attorneys for guidance
uh legalzoom is not a law firm you can
get self-help services at your
specific direction or you can speak to a
legal
legal plan attorney sorry to get your
questions answered
and get ongoing advice before another
year passes
passes you by cross a couple things off
your new year's checklist today at
legalzoom.com and save a pile of money
while doing it
entered bur burr in the referral box and
check out
for even more savings at legalzoom.com
good lord is that just literally
directed at me i got to do all of that
stuff i got to get a will
you know i got to make sure all my ducks
are in a row here considering i
fly every other weekend do you see that
freaking story where they
they had to ground that airplane they
had a problem with the battery
had the problem with the battery you
know like your car except it's a [ __ ]
plane
you know i don't know what the hell i'm
talking about all right let's get back
to lance armstrong
so oprah had an in-depth interview with
lance armstrong
it was a dumbest it was actually [ __ ]
hilarious i was watching it with the
lovely nia
and uh i was just
laughing my ass off it was it was
phenomenal
like she's sitting there going like um
so were you were you
basically injecting you know [ __ ]
horse jizz steroids into you for every
race
and he's like yes yes i was for all
tours he's like yes i was
she's like did you consider it cheating
and he's like
at the time no no i didn't
it's like of course he didn't you know
what pissed me off about lance i guess
it was kind of a good move on his part
that he didn't go like oprah
did you do any research into this sport
did you notice the top 20 guys were all
[ __ ] doing this [ __ ] too
you got to fight fire with fire you
can't bring a knife to a gunfight if
everybody else is jacked up i got to be
jacked up too for [ __ ] sakes
the worst thing though i didn't i
actually liked the oprah interview and
it was kind of funny watching her be
dumbfounded
by this guy's complete lack of uh
you know just not giving a [ __ ] when he
was cheating
um and then the whole thing was funny to
me because i you know i'm old enough to
remember when oprah used to interview
[ __ ] midgets who want to [ __ ] their
mailman's brother you know
so i don't know i feel like she kind of
cheated her way up too didn't she did
you kind of host a carnival show to get
where you were acting and then all of a
sudden you went like
wait a minute i've been doing some soul
searching
that's completely not the same thing i
just like making fun of oprah
so um anyways they do the whole
interview and then
uh they go on uh espn
this this was like espn this week was
just a total male
hissy fit you know that stupid notre
dame story
have you ever seen more of a non-fucking
story in your life
why do i give a [ __ ] about that he
didn't lie to me
i don't even care if he knew it was a
made-up person and he wanted more
attention
i think that's [ __ ] hilarious that's
hilarious to me and if he got away with
it good for him
i don't give a [ __ ] why do i give a [ __ ]
if anybody for the love of god like four
or five days
so this is it it takes today it takes
another bizarre
turn i
don't know i i you know what i so don't
give a [ __ ] i don't have anything funny
to say about it
you know it's funny that nia finally
wanted to pay attention to espn
and uh what i ended up doing was because
i couldn't listen to it for more than a
minute i just hit record on sportscenter
for the first time ever i recorded
sportscenter for her
and i had to turn the channel because i
don't give a [ __ ] about a football
player's love life
you know nobody died
right nobody got killed there was no
nobody
you know you would have thought a double
murder happened i don't know so anyway
so i'm watching [ __ ] rick riley
rick riley's talking about lance
armstrong and i guess rick riley
was backing lance and he was just having
this hissy fit
about his reputation because he back
lance armstrong
like anybody gives a flying [ __ ] about
rick riley
and when lance armstrong when he finally
you know came out that he did it did
anybody go
like oh my god
now what happens to rick riley like he
made that whole [ __ ] thing about
himself
you know he made he said he made me look
like a fool
i was typing things supporting him
rick relax nobody's blaming you nobody
gives a flying [ __ ] this this really
isn't on you
this is about lance this isn't about you
okay
so why don't you uh just close your
laptop [ __ ] relax
like he felt betrayed
like rick what are you [ __ ] special
he lied to the whole world he's not
gonna lie to you
like hey rick listen i know i just went
on national television and said that i
uh
i i don't cheat in those races but i i i
actually am cheating
uh i've cheated every race and i plan to
continue cheating in the future
and now that you know that um
i have to kill you you know
i don't know i was really hoping for
more on all both of those subjects
i would was hoping that i was going to
have something a little more funnier
you know what is i just i'm worn out
i don't give a f i just
i watched that [ __ ] game yesterday
and we lost
and nia was going to go see lady gaga
last night
and at the last second her friend bailed
actually the day before her friend
bailed so she goes do you want to go
would you
go with me and i was just like yeah i'll
[ __ ] go to that i'll go to it
you know i'm a comedian i need to know
what the [ __ ] going on in pop culture
i will go to this stuff and i'll go to
this thing and she goes do you realize
how funny it's going to be
if somebody who listens to your podcast
is at that thing and sees you at that
and i said yeah it's going to be [ __ ]
hilarious
so i went down there getting ready to
see you know
no let's let's tell this in
chronological order i'm watching
the patriots game over a buddy of mine's
house and i'm just
pounding beers i don't know why
i bought a 12-pack they were set up and
i just felt like i had to knock them all
down
and i think i think i had at least seven
of them if not eight now somebody else
was digging into them too i can't
[ __ ] remember
you know one of those things where
you're not really totally hammered but
you forget your sunglasses you don't
like that kind of level drunk
[Laughter]
so now i gotta race home
and uh you know i shut myself off in the
third quarter just like i'm at the game
i just start drinking waters and eating
[ __ ] chicken wings and [ __ ]
and uh sober up jump in the car drive
home
put on a shirt no wait no we took a cab
that's right we ended up taking a cab
over to staples center and we missed the
opening act which i'm like bonus
because i know i'm not going to like
them and we come [ __ ] walking into
the staples center and right as the show
starts
and lady gaga comes out of a fake castle
on a horse
and starts walking around the arena you
know they do that big thing now they got
like the big [ __ ] half a semi-circle
loop with a bunch of [ __ ]
raven kids in the middle of it and um
that's what started it off and then she
sang one of her songs
and then uh then she went back into the
castle
and then all of a sudden it looked like
it was a turkey with its legs spread
and uh she came out of the vagina that
unzipped it and came out of that
you know and then sang another [ __ ]
song
you know a bunch of shredded gay guys
old five six seven eight all at the same
[ __ ] time
and then she just starts spewing this
[ __ ]
self-help horseshit you know
doing that stupid dramatic pause to milk
the crowd she's just like you know
it's great to be here tonight los
angeles everybody's like
she's just like i got a message out
there for anyone who's ever felt
different
if you feel different know that and all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] about being
it was literally like it was like
gay spinal tap
it was honestly it was a terrible
[ __ ] show
terrible show the [ __ ] dancing was
terrible she can sing
but she stinks at dancing she's on a
[ __ ] horse
she comes out of a vagina how many times
has that been done
why'd you come out of the vagina lady
gag let me guess this album was a
rebirth for you
you [ __ ] hack ripping off madonna
right and left first of all she's got
that one
song that i i don't know what madonna's
song is i never know i
and whenever i hear it i start singing
the other madonna song
she's ripping off madonna right down
she had a black jesus
and the crowd's eating it up and all and
at first i'm like you got to be [ __ ]
she's doing the black jesus thing
like a prayer am i the only guy i looked
around i was like oh my god i'm old
i'm old i'm [ __ ] old and i'm sitting
there and all i want to do is just start
trashing
i want to start heckling which i did a
couple times and nia just gave me the
look and i was like i'm i i can't ruin
this for her
she was going to go here with somebody
else who's going to be waving glow
sticks and i agreed to come here i can't
be a [ __ ]
so um i'm not glad you guys sat down
after the
first [ __ ] song and uh
it was really difficult to listen to it
was really [ __ ] annoying
way more annoying than i thought it was
going to be i thought it was going to be
all right you know
still going to be on some level i'll
appreciate it this is
pop [ __ ] i can try to come here and
enjoy this [ __ ] and it was
it just really wasn't a good show i
can't [ __ ]
oh with the stupid dramatic pauses why
do singers always have to look up in the
air halfway through a sentence
and just get another applause break
i saw a band the other night in this
little [ __ ] club and the guy was
doing that
he was like you know this is the first
time
then he looks up the ceiling and it's
just dead silence and then the crowd
always gives in to the [ __ ]
silence i don't know if they feel
uncomfortable with and they just feel
they have to fill it up by going
then the guy finishes the sentence that
we've been in los angeles in three years
it's like why couldn't you just complete
that sentence
why couldn't you just go hey you know
this is the first time we've been in los
angeles for
like three years and we're happy to be
back because you guys are great fans
you could do that and like [ __ ] what
was that how long did it take me to say
that 3.5 seconds
it takes him like 30 seconds
los angeles is a city
that's on the west coast of this country
and you know
that was [ __ ] horrible so anyways
lady gaga is on stage
i can't believe i have this [ __ ]
story i feel like i dreamed it
um she just goes you know she
finishes another one her [ __ ]
horseshit songs i think at that point
she was like dry humping a yak
to protest uh some sort of middle
eastern thing i don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on
and by the way her drummer was the [ __ ]
and i really would have enjoyed watching
him but he appeared to be in the dungeon
section inside the [ __ ] castle
because god forbid that somebody else
out on the [ __ ] stage taken away from
your [ __ ] horseshit
oh my god and then she had she had two
plants in the crowd
two clear [ __ ] plants she calls some
[ __ ] young gay kid on the crowd and
tells him it's okay and the kid starts
[ __ ] he's like how did you get his
number
when did you get his number how did they
have him miked up
how can i hear this guy clear his
[ __ ] day talking into a [ __ ] cell
phone
that's going through the roof of the
staples center to outer space back down
to the [ __ ]
through the roof again to lady gaga
who's got drapes around her [ __ ] head
right crowd's eating it up
like oh my god she's a saint look at her
reaching out right
and then the worst part was she she's
sitting there dancing around
and she's only a little bit better
dancer than i am and i'm [ __ ]
horrific so she's up there
um and then she goes where's that guy
with the green hair in the crowd
get up on the stage you know because
she's so down to earth
and the dude the green haired dude gets
up on the [ __ ] stage
shirtless shredded right so right there
you know it's a plant although there
were a lot of gay guys there
gay guys are always [ __ ] shredded so
i'll give them the benefit of the doubt
on that
so the shirtless [ __ ] shredded dude
with the green hair gets on
runs up the runway doing his best to act
like he's shocked
and then they go into this [ __ ] dance
routine and this dude knows
every [ __ ] move right down to when to
leave with the other dancers and walk
into the castle
it's like why is he going into the
castle i thought he was just some random
guy you pulled out of the [ __ ] crowd
shouldn't he go back to his goddamn seat
how much of a grumpy [ __ ] am i that i'm
really ripping this [ __ ] apart it was
[ __ ] i i
i gotta tell you i was really uh i was
really disappointed
i felt like i put myself in the in the
headspace where i could enjoy this
i was already seven beers in i grabbed a
little bit of mcdonald's on the way in
i had a court upon it with chiefs with
some french fries i'm like all right
let's see
uh let's see this [ __ ] let's see this
i know she can sing
so it should be halfway decent and it
just was
uh ending the songs and then just
sitting there with [ __ ]
every time drapes around her face it's
like when are you just going to accept
your nose
we get it you don't like your nose but
you're afraid to get a nose job because
you think it's going to change the sound
of your voice just
when are you you're sitting there
telling all these young gay kids
it's okay that they're different and
here it is you can't even accept your
face walking around like that chick from
the ring
your hair all in your goddamn face
so [ __ ] awful and finishing every
song and then she just sit there
all wrapped in drapes and then being all
like
breathing into the mic which was super
[ __ ] annoying
then she was like i hope you guys are
having a good time tonight
because if you're not i don't give a
[ __ ]
i said i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
the whole crowd goes nuts then she
proceeds to give a [ __ ] speech about
how much she doesn't give a [ __ ]
goes over to another shredded gay guy
[ __ ] backup dancer
you know hey [ __ ] soliloquy do you do
you give a [ __ ] he's like
i don't give a [ __ ] either either either
i think that's when i heckled and i got
my first dirty look from there because
it's literally like you know if you
don't give a [ __ ]
get on with the not giving a [ __ ] why
would you stop and give a speech
you know that's something i've learned
in life is if you don't give a [ __ ]
you just you you don't say you don't
give a [ __ ]
if you don't give a [ __ ] other people
they recognize it and they say it for
you
hey dude you know you know that kid uh
you know that kid mike
yeah yeah dude that kid he doesn't give
a [ __ ] seriously that kid and then you
tell the [ __ ] story
but mike isn't walking around going you
know
telling everybody that he doesn't give a
[ __ ]
she clearly gives a [ __ ] she gives a
[ __ ] how she looks i don't think she
likes the way she looks and i think that
that's why she's [ __ ] walking around
with an
afghan or [ __ ] i don't know what you
call it
upholstery all over her [ __ ] face
i don't know whatever well should i just
enjoy the
the the i don't know the [ __ ]
i don't know what i was really i mean as
dumb as this sounds
i went there with some sort of
expectations and i just you know i
thought the drummer was the best part of
the [ __ ] show and he was he was in a
castle and i couldn't [ __ ] see him
granted his
his drumsticks were lit up
so i could see some of the [ __ ] that he
was doing but uh
i don't know and then there was some
sort there was some sort of story going
on
i felt like they were like workshopping
a musical and they didn't really have
the full story
they just kept being this face that
would glow up and it was lady gaga's and
she would just be speaking monotone like
she was some sort of zombie
which i guess was supposed to give it
some sort of depth can you guys believe
that somebody
44 gonna be 45 is wasting this much time
talking about how i was disappointed at
a lady gaga concert as if
that [ __ ] show in any shape or form
was designed
to appeal to some [ __ ] redheaded [ __ ]
like me
you know whatever i i had to get that
out
because there's a chance nia might be
coming down to the podcast
and and i did a real good job
not taking the piss out of that show
when i was there and not ruining it for
but uh anyways
[ __ ] it was really bad
you know what i mean even madonna
concerts back in the [ __ ] day
oh that was another thing that she
[ __ ] said she was going like you know
when i started out
out dramatic pause
people didn't think that i could bring
the underground gay scene
to the mainstream you know
it's like why are you ignoring madonna
didn't madonna do that like 20 years ago
didn't the village people kind of start
it you know what's funny about
like it was so it was that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] underground
in the 70s right into the 80s that
morons like me
didn't know that like half the people
you were listening to
were gay yeah no even though like you'd
be listening to a band called
queen and the guy's prancing around
in his in [ __ ] i don't know what the
diapers adult diapers i don't know what
he was doing walking around barefoot
you still like the music was you didn't
you still didn't know
i watched the other day i was watching
this judas priest concert
uh i forget where the [ __ ] they were it
was like in the earl
early 80s and rob halford is coming out
like
in like literally [ __ ]
like essen this s m outfit
and you had no [ __ ] idea um
i don't know there's like 20 guys like
that it was still underground but like
that madonna's [ __ ] when she did
all that vogue and crap that was like 20
almost 25 years at this point so i don't
know
i think that's just what it is i think
i'm just an old [ __ ] guy
and i imagine when i was watching
whatever the [ __ ] i was watching they
were all going dude zeppelin did this
like 15 years ago
as i'm sitting there freaking out
watching a band called cinderella
i think that was the point of it no
offense to lady gaga fans i think i just
realized how [ __ ] old i was
all right and i just watched my team
lose okay stamps.com everybody uh intro
i'm not supposed to read intro part um
if you haven't heard yet postage rates
are changing again
you know what that means the post office
will be even more crowded than usual
yeah because a bunch of old people
running down there to get their stamps
because the bankers stole their 401k
okay that's the real story behind this
advertising
um stamps.com that's why i use
stamps.com um to send out all my dvds
each and every week by the way the hard
copy of you people of all the same
is uh going to be coming out soon and i
will be selling that at the end of all
my live shows and eventually on my
website
and how will i get those dvds to my
shows
well i'll be using stamps.com dog dog on
it
um why because i can buy and print
official us postage right from my
desk using my own computer and printer
stamps.com always updates the postage
rates for you automatically
and unlike those postage meters
companies stamps.coms never charges a
fee to do it
so with stance.com you will always get
the exact postage you need for any
letter
or package the instant you need it
you'll never have to go to the post
office again
um i gotta tell you it's a dream it's a
dream to not have to do that i've been
using stamps.com for the last
uh let's say when the hell did i start
doing this
a little over a year or maybe right
about a year
anyways it's been easy it's totally
convenient i love it i can be in my
sweatpants and my bare feetsies and send
out my dvds uh right now i have a
special offer for you when you use my
last name burp b-u-r-r
no risk trial plus 110 bonus including a
digital scale
in up to 55 dollars free postage don't
wait go to stamps.com right now before
you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr
that stamps dot com enter bur b-u-r-r um
all right sad news this week
um on the podcast uh the great earl
weaver
earl weaver weaver
he i'm sorry he passed away uh this week
and
uh he was one of my favorites he's a
throwback coach
uh we got a great clip of him
um
he's there's two great clips of him i i
gotta find the other one was he
it hit the first one is when he comes
out and he's arguing i believe it's a
buck
and he's yelling at that umpire and he
goes you know what you are out here
for one goddamn reason and the umpire is
hilarious he goes why is that earl and
he goes
to [ __ ] us he's like ah that's a bunch
of balls that is that's true
you came out here to [ __ ] us
and you know what's great is the umpire
is just so sick of earl weaver he's like
ah
yeah because earl weaver like threatens
him he goes ah earl you're not gonna
knock anybody on your ass
he goes what are you gonna do [ __ ] up
another world series
i think he was making reference to the
fact they were up three games to one
against the pirates i was too young i
don't know if earl made some bad calls
with the
um you know the pitchers he put in or
whatever
i think it was more the pirates it was
just their destiny to win that year
but uh the empire literally says to do
what earl
[ __ ] up another world series and he said
well and earl goes i've won more than
i've lost
and the umpire's like no you haven't no
you haven't and earl goes i'm talking
about
games that's [ __ ] hilarious
see umpire's basically calling him out
going you lost more world series that
you managed and then you won
and earl goes with the technicality yeah
but i won more world series games it's
[ __ ] hilarious
um you know
i really hope i just don't think that
there's going to be another guy like him
this day and age would like to actually
get audio back then was so rare where
nowadays i just feel like
i don't know they just don't go off the
way they used to
they were just some great ones and he
was he was the best of the best i would
say earl weaver as far as yelling
at an umpire might have been the jordan
or the bobby knight i would say of uh
i bobby knight always came off like a
baby to me
you know like throwing chairs like a
little kid throwing his toys and stuff
he always came off like a baby to me and
a phony tough guy earl weaver
er weaver to me just kind of came off
like uh just like a he was just like a
[ __ ] badger
you know a little wolverine or something
like that i don't know there was just
something [ __ ]
because he was his little guy the
greatest thing about this clip is i
think he walks away like four times
and every time he stops and walks back
the crowd goes even crazier
and it was almost like watching hulk
hogan like milking a crowd
right before he rips his shirt off it's
just i don't know any it's another thing
that makes me feel old
um the late great earl weaver
passes away so anyways hey let's check
in on the brew and see how they're doing
here
um i love this by the way this is free
advertising
it's still one to one in the second
period i love this by the way when you
can [ __ ] uh
you can watch the games you get the
package on the computer because i'm on
the
i got a big tour coming up everybody i'm
really excited about this
and um i'm playing all these
unbelievable venues and uh i don't know
i get amped up for this like
[ __ ] like if i was playing sports you
know
going to all these places and just
wanting to make sure you know you give
people their money's worth
um i'm going to be at the wilbur theater
the wilba
um february 21st
22nd and i believe the 23rd right the
patrice o'neill benefit is february 19th
thursday's the 24th yeah february 21st
22nd and 23rd
two shows a night um
oh and i don't know if there's tickets
still available but i'm doing two
benefits next week
on the patrice o'neil one is sold out
there is a chance that some tickets at
the last second might be made available
depending on uh we got to make sure all
family and friends get their tickets
uh we set aside some so uh there might
be some extra ones i'll give you guys
the heads up
on twitter um
but on monday the 18th i'm doing a
benefit
for a good friend of mine uh vinnie mark
whose wife
is uh battling cancer and uh i'm doing
it
at the bananas hasbro heights
i know tickets are on sale for that one
i think that one one of my sold out too
but uh just in case there are some
tickets both of those are wonderful
causes obviously
and then i get to go my big home my
homecoming there go to the wilbur
theater
21st 22nd 23rd and
all the rest of the dates are up on my
website uh
in march um at the barrymore theater
wisconsin
madison wisconsin pabst theater
milwaukee wisconsin
fountain street church grand rapids
michigan on march 9th
royal oak march 10th so those dates 7 8
10. i'm going through wisconsin in
michigan
22nd i'm in at the egyptian room in
indianapolis
i'm at the state third march 23rd in
minneapolis minnesota
and then i'm down the tabernacle
tabernacle
in atlanta georgia april 12th more dates
to come
um philly dc chicago
some of the ones that are on top of my
head
um we got some gigs in texas
whatever i'm gonna be all over the place
so
oh also calgary edmonton and vancouver i
think i'm finally doing shows up there
speaking of hockey um like i said we'll
be are we
announcing them as uh as the dates come
up i just don't want to announce them
and then not have tickets
for sale you know what i mean so anyways
back to the podcast here let's read some
uh let's read some questions here
where the [ __ ] am i
oh by the way i think i'm going to be
going to the masters again this year
should be another good time here all
right uh response to kid wanting to move
to florida hey bill listening to this
week's podcast oh this was from last
week
with that 24 year old kid who's about
ready to get married was sick in new
york and wanted to move down to florida
and i was giving him some advice saying
he was young it was a good time to do it
but uh
just know that you are moving a world
away from um
jersey and new york so anyways he says
listen to le this guy says listening to
this week's podcast
and just want to throw in my two cents
about uh this kid wanting to move to
florida
as i was in the exact same situation as
this guy i think you gave some great
advice
thank you making a big change and moving
away from family friends etc is a big
change
and it takes a while to get that same
setup going in your new place
the only additional advice that i could
give to this guy is to travel
check out places and see what he and his
girlfriend like try chicago
portland la san diego austin etc those
are some great cities you just picked
there by the way uh each have their own
vibe and attitude
and job markets you were spot on
uh with the new york northeast attitude
i think he's talking to me now
it's it's foot on the floor get out of
the way i found it to be too comfort
too confrontational and self-centered
i guess when he lived other places and
this guy seems to have a
similar outfit look unfortunately i
think his girlfriend is right new york
isn't going to change
he's just going to become more bitter
and if they get a house mortgage kids
etc it probably only gets worse and he
feels like he's tied down to the
the place he's in like you said he's
young enough trying to make a move and
if it doesn't work he can move back
i just say he should do some traveling
and scout first
at a minimum it gives him a break from
the new york attitude and lets you clear
your head and get a perspective
uh best case he finds somewhere that
seems like a fit
for his and his girlfriend's
personalities yeah that's a huge [ __ ]
thing
you know what i mean you definitely want
to travel around and try some [ __ ] out
because if you just go to one place god
forbid you don't like it but your girl
or your boyfriend
loves it and then you're stuck there uh
i know somebody like that they moved to
tampa
and the dude loves it and his wife is
[ __ ] miserable
you see it on her face every time i see
her hey he's still kind of
not liking it and she's just you know
you're warming up to it a little bit she
just [ __ ] shakes her head slowly
and you know the guy's an idiot he's
like i don't know what a problem is i
love it
you know it's like
i don't know how he does that i couldn't
if neil was miserable living somewhere
you know once if you're [ __ ] if your
girl is miserable that's it man you got
to get the [ __ ]
out of there she's going to bring that
misery down on you
all right men are studs women are [ __ ]
um i had that conversation last week
with the lovely nia
she says bill my wife and i went to a
marriage retreat one summer
and the guest speaker said a quote that
stuck with me
the quote was a key that can open many
locks is called a master key
a lock that can be opened with many key
is considered
useless just a bit of ammunition the
next time you get into a heated argument
stay safe go [ __ ] yourself
um i would love to say that i get it
i get that quote but i don't get it as
it pertains to men are studs women or
[ __ ]
because uh i know what i was saying that
the reason why if a guy goes out and
bangs a bunch of women he's a stud he's
a stud because that's a skill
he has to talk all those women into bed
he's got a woman
he's got to seduce him you know he's got
to spin him around the dance floor he's
got to tell some jokes he's got to spin
the plates
women can just show up be like all right
who wants it line it up
you know and they can have a [ __ ] 10
on one if they want to
you know what i mean that's what i was
saying so he says a key that can open
many locks
is considered a master key so i guess
that that's the guy being able to talk
all the broads in bed
a lock that can be opened with many keys
is considered
useless
that's where it goes off the rails for
me
and [ __ ] all you guys who are laughing
at me i don't get it
because i don't know if you kind of look
at guys we for the most part we will
[ __ ] anything that moves so we can also
be considered useless
let around by our dicks you know
i really wish if i could go back and be
young again
and go back to that lady gaga concert
sorry um
oh there's another dumb [ __ ] thing
she said then annoyed me
if you want to do something and people
say you
can't do it long pause
you just rule the [ __ ] over them right
nobody goes [ __ ] nuts
and that statement really bugged me it's
like you know you're really speaking to
like 20 000 people at this point lady
gaga don't you think
you shouldn't be painting with such a
broad brush don't you think you should
maybe realize what the [ __ ] some people
are thinking what if you have a
pedophile in the crowd you're thinking
of doing something
and people say you shouldn't do it you
roll the [ __ ] over you know son
what do you got a pyromaniac you know
just because somebody's got green hair
and abs doesn't automatically mean they
have the best of intentions
so why don't you [ __ ] take your
sweaty face out from underneath all that
carpet you got wrapped around i've been
thinking about what you're talking about
is my computer gonna crash here running
out of [ __ ]
running out of juice here uh let's read
the last advertising just in case
uh e-voice oh i like this this is
awesome e-voice
e-voice is what professionals use to
save time and work smarter e-voice
converts all your voicemails to texts
and sends it directly to your cell phone
right there right there alone it's worth
it's worth the price of admission
uh no interrupting your day to check
your voicemail or waiting till after a
meeting to find out what's going on
with e-voice your calls will always be
routed to you no matter where you are
e-voice also comes with your own
conference line for up to 94
participants on one single call
the bilderberg group could use e-voice
um it's all
it all starts for less than ten dollars
per month but right now they have a
special offer for our podcast listeners
you get e-voice for free for six months
with no obligation dude ten bucks a
month is almost free
um for your free six-month trial go to
www.evoice.com and enter the the promo
code bill b
i l l e voice can make your small
business sound professional like a
fortune 500 company
they can create your own customer custom
professional greeting
e-voice provides a dial by name
directory so you'll sound like the big
boys it's the greatest thing ever if you
if you're starting out a business or
even if you already have one
to just immediately sound professionals
the second people start
talking to you going to your voicemail
if it sounds like you know
some run-of-the-mill five and dime if it
sounds
cheesy you know i don't want to speak
for everybody but i'm hanging up so uh
definitely use uh go to e-voice
it's ten dollars a month and you get the
first six months for free i mean you
really can't beat that okay
am i bringing you the deals here or what
all right back to the podcast
let me read this one before the whole
thing crashes here
maybe because i'm watching the bruins
game at the same time is that's what's
sucking away all the energy
still one to one after two
marshawn doing the interview hoping he
comes on this year
it's a little off last year is it me was
it me he had a kind of an off year
uh relationship advice for a lady
um oh wait i skipped one now let's do
the lady one here
[ __ ] trash and lady gaga let's let's
try to help out one of the broads there
i'm emailing you tonight with the hopes
of of saving my relationship
yes that's right bill burr you just
might be the savior
to the only thing that truly matters to
me oh okay great
no pressure here um
please if you do so if you care about
okay i met my boyfriend
in 2010 yes a shitty college bar
in shipmansburg pennsylvania
if you were to ask any former or current
student from ship what's the best bar
and ship they tell you this place
and rave about it as if it was the
[ __ ] taj mahal
mahal uh the fact that our story began
in this place might be an indication
that there is something seriously
bizarre about our relationship but i
assure you we're pretty normal people
no i mean meeting somebody when you're
college age if you're in a college bar
and
you you can there's still you're still
drafting in the first round you know
what i mean everybody's 21 22.
you meet some broad in a bar at [ __ ]
you know 28
29 you know that's where you know you're
trying to find that
you know i don't know that diamond in
the rough in the [ __ ] sixth round
that's like the fourth round by then
once you get in the 30s that's just like
you know
supplemental draft anyways in the past
two and a half years
i've i've been i have known and have
been with him
he's been an avid fan of yours i took
him to a show of yours
at the tower theater and upper darby and
we hope we hopped in the front of the
line
for the meet and greet where he
proceeded to thank you for having him
as if you personally invited him i've i
have yet to let his star struck moment
go it's something we still laugh at all
the time oh that's great you break his
balls
good you're a hot [ __ ] um he's the
writer of
you